[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we make way for
greg anthony who was a member of that
unlv team
tnt by the way the exclusive coverage of
the nba all-star game this sunday
greg working for tnt and nba analyst as
well what do you think of that uh list
there greg
it might be a little bogus okay
just a little but you know it is really
difficult to compare
teams and what you know this stand being
in the business as long as you have
all that is is a bunch of people's
opinion and the vast majority of the
people who gave that opinion didn't see
any of those teams but
so you got to take that stuff with with
a great assault they listen
they were all great teams and it's one
thing about the tournament
uh and i've always said this is one of
the things that we love about it is that
oftentimes the best team doesn't win you
know
and you talked about that georgetown
team
they were three points away from one in
three straight
they lost at the basically at the buzzer
to carolina that great carolina team
right
by one they then beat uh
i think they beat uh houston houston
next year then they lose to villanova by
two when villanova shot 79
in the second half you know so
to say that anybody really was better
than that
you know you you got to say to not have
a luau cinderella
team in the top five from ucla is a
to me a little suspect so you know
i do want to ask you a question though
mr patrick because i was listening
i had the good fortune of being able to
listen to your dire tribe a little
earlier before i came on and you guys
were
going off on james harden and all these
guys
and i would just ask you guys one thing
think of it like a divorce
divorces can be messy until the emotions
subside
and then eventually you know the greater
good comes out what's most important a
lot of times you got kids or whatever
and you move on and so
james harden is one of the five greatest
houston rockets of all time
okay i put dream on there i think y'all
deserves to be on that list uh moses
malone
and elvin hayes to me those are the five
greatest of all or drexler's in there
no drex is not on that direction only
played two three years
he's not on that list he's on the
portland you know he he was on
he got traded seeds in the second oh i'm
thinking of five slam pajama my bad
great yeah you think of houston i'm
sorry
okay but what i'm saying is you know
this is the same
scenario that played out with anthony
davis when he left new orleans
and it's and it's also no different when
a team you guys were saying he quit
what did the team do what do teams do
when they decide hey we're not going to
play you anymore because we're looking
to trade
aren't those teams quitting on the
player by that
standard yeah james harden
yeah but andre drummond's playing for a
team that's not going anywhere james
harden helped build a team though greg
and divorces can be messy you know
gwyneth paltrow can uncouple with chris
martin
and it's okay or you can have your
spouse cheat on you
there's a big difference in those two
and james harden wanted out
after he helped build a team he's the
one that
constructed and deconstructed that's why
i could never vote for him for mvp this
year with what he did well i i i
disagree with that think of it this way
when you when you go and you basically
you fire
a future hall of fame gm and darrell
mori you fire a future coach
future hall of fame coach and mike
d'antoni and you
hire guys who have never done the jobs
before
in the midst of the prime of my career
when i'm at a point now where i'm
probably on the back nine
and this is my last chance to have an
opportunity to win a title
so you just told me we're about to
rebuild
um and we're not only are we rebuilding
we're going to take a chance with our
rebuild because the people we're hiring
have never done the job before
and so at that point as a as a dominant
player
which james harden is i think it's time
in his mind he wanted to move on and and
again it's not that he didn't enjoy his
time in houston it's not that they
didn't give it a go
you know i'm always amused when people
want to blame
james hart oh you know you know he
didn't he didn't win a championship
the only team i mean he played the
golden state warriors one of the
greatest teams of all time
they got four guys who are gonna go in
the hall of fame
james harden had a year and a half two
years with chris paul chris paul doesn't
get hurt they probably won that series
you know we we blame a great player it's
no different than when lebron
couldn't beat san antonio early in his
career they got four hall of famers
he's not playing with other hall of
famers when he's on those cleveland
teams
you know winning is is not a guarantee
and i don't blame a guy for
not having as good a team as another
team now he never stepped up in a big
moment
he never stepped up appointments in the
postseason though i'm with you there but
i'm just saying
that guy's an all-time great what
all-time great wouldn't want an
opportunity to win a championship
towards the latter stages of his career
like i'm not
upset at him for wanting out and quite
frankly houston
could have probably handled it better
it's not like
it was a surprise to them at that point
and so
both sides deserve a little bit of blame
but i will tell you this
the fans there will and are appreciative
of what james harden did james harden
was a great
player for the houston rockets he made
them relevant absolutely
and all you gotta do is look at what's
going on now
james has moved on on a championship
caliber team the rockets are in the
midst of a 11-game losing streak
he's greg anthony tnt nba analyst uh
lebron asked for the night off or gets
the night off against sacramento tonight
how do you think that works where does
lebron
say i want the night i i'm always
curious about that greg
do you think greg that he just goes in
and goes um
i'm thinking about taking the night off
and then frank vogel goes you know i'm
thinking you should take the night off
lebron
and then lebron take the night off
lebron is so calculated then i think
what happened is
there were messages sent from his people
to the lakers
so that ultimately the way it plays out
is that
the team decides he's going to have the
night off so he has
plausible deniability yeah to be able to
say
i didn't want to take that up i'm here
to play because that's the one thing
that lebron
can hold over everybody else in the
league right now think about it
18th year in on a team that's a
defending champ
he's going to have all the records there
are all this talk about guys
not playing load managing all that stuff
and here's a guy that hadn't missed the
game all season yeah
short off season uh team is in disarray
right now because of all the injuries
that you know they've lost uh five out
of the last seven games
uh and so but in he has the ability to
say look i wanted to play
but the team just felt this was in the
best interest moving forward
and he has the plausible deniability of
not having to say that i asked for the
name
i'm watching the game last night and you
know booker gets tossed
uh it it wasn't a great performance by
phoenix but you
beat la in l.a like phoenix is real to
me greg
i and oh yeah and and i i think chris
paul
and you played a point guard position
like you know
like he just gives stability there like
there's something about
chris paul on the floor i can't put my
hand on it finger on it
but it's there it's real and to have a
young team there
um and it feels like they're they're in
it for the long haul this season
absolutely i think it's a great
assessment on your part listen
leadership right now you know sometimes
we get caught up in
stats right and got oh he's averaging
almost a triple-double
stats it's like football stats are a
little skewed right now right because
if you would have looked at a
quarterback from the 70s or the 80s
and you just looked at their numbers
there's no way in hell they're getting
the hall of fame today
right because they're not throwing
they're not putting up the number they
didn't throw it 60 times again back then
50 times again
and in basketball similarly the numbers
are a little skewed
you know scoring's way up the rule
changes all those things have played a
role in it and so
i always tell people when you're looking
at it to me the biggest stat is wins and
losses
and like right now you know if you want
to talk about the real
mvp contenders to me chris paul is
clearly top fire
maybe higher to the point you make a
young team
he's teaching a team how to win like you
made a great point
everybody wins in the league when they
play their best
the really good teams can win when they
don't and
last night was indicative of that for
phoenix they win a game
when they didn't play their best their
most talented player gets tossed
but they still figure out a way and
chris paul's stats don't blow you away
last night
no you know but a lot of leadership
has nothing to do with the game it's
preparation it's
connection it's trust it's
accountability it's all these other
things that he has brought there
they were on the verge of making a step
but and the other thing and you notice
that
people don't understand the weight of
expectation
you know so look at denver and look at
dallas coming into this year
high expectations right because of based
on what they did last year
and they struggled early and there are
reasons why you got
guys out injury blah blah blah but the
reality is they hadn't performed like
a lot of people thought phoenix had the
same expectations
they won all eight games in the bubble
you know devin booker's playing terrific
um they bring in chris paul a lot of
expectations
and up until a couple days ago they had
the fourth best record in league
um so to me that's value that's what
value is to me
it's not just what stats are guys giving
you it's the impact he's having on your
organization
in terms of winning and chris paul has
done that in spades and yeah the lakers
will tell you look they didn't
not only did they not have anthony davis
they didn't have kyle kuzma either
i mean it it's tough they're still but
if lebron's on the floor
they still have a chance to win we all
know that so give phoenix a lot of
credit they're a really good basketball
team
and they're also really good at winning
time which is even more important and
that speaks to the impact
of a guy like chris paul it's always
great to mix it up with you greg i hope
you're well
i'm doing great probably the 18 foot
jumper that's about it right
at 15 to 18 like you're there yeah i
take my youngest son out
in the back you know on the hoop here at
the house and i can still
whenever i need to build up my
confidence i take him out and kick his
ass
you know like just but he's only four
though greg that's the thing
oh he's nine he's so oh okay
because he was he was kicking my tail
too often what was that like though when
when cole
when when you realized that your son was
better than you
oh man he was uh
it's about six seven years ago and uh
we're playing in the backyard and i'm
gonna be
cause like at this point physically he
had matured right and so
he was quicker stronger he's just better
but i still had experience so i'm
battling it and he wins the first game
so we do it best two or three we're tied
at point
on the second game i've
both my achilles and hamstrings felt
like they were about to tear
and the only out i had was i said look
i'm going to have to call it right now
because i don't want to risk injury
for fear ruining my golf game i said so
we're going gonna call this a wash
and he lost it because he's like no
i'm up and we're tied i said
he's like this is not a watch but i i
never
acknowledged that he won but i will say
he had good he had a good chance of
winning that day if we were able to
finish but the game got called today
and he's doing pretty well with orlando
averaging uh leaving a game in his
rookie season
he's doing well uh thank you for joining
us greg we appreciate it as always bob
anytime my friend you'd be safe that's
greg anthony tnt nba
tv analyst and tnt will uh carry the
nba all-star game coming up this sunday